the world of pixar villainy is one
filled with humor deviousness and some
of the strongest nemesis to ever shine
upon the silver screen but while some
pixar baddies are cinematic legends
others won't stand the test of time join
us as we rank the pixar villains from
worst to best
cars 2 is not a favorite among pixar
fans and that distaste extends to the
film's main villain miles axelrod a hot
shot moneybags car voiced by eddie
izzard what me
got to be crazy axelrod a character
constructed as some kind of richard
branson automobile equivalent carries
with him the fate of the car's universe
as his plan to use his fake
environmentally friendly fuel to achieve
world domination can only be stopped by
who else that lovable tow truck known as
mater the laziness in the plot and lack
of any enjoyable humor at any moment is
perfectly represented in axelrod a
facsimile of the type of villain that's
been portrayed in far superior films
than this one
simplicity can definitely be a good
thing on occasion but when it comes to
pixar villains the simple approach can
sometimes mean a character's ultimate
downfall take thunderclap for example a
not so nice pterodactyl who given the
few other options present in this
prehistoric adventure acts as the de
facto villain character of pixar's the
good dinosaur thunderclap is a deranged
wisecracking beast that leads a pack of
fellow storm-chasing pterodactyls in
their quest to try and eat arlo the
dinosaur's human companion spot that's
really it honestly which leads to
thunderclap's low position on this list
a character so forgettable partly
because of his lack of any real powerful
motivation within the world of the good
dinosaur
the cars films as financially successful
as they were really don't represent a
huge artistic zenith for pixar in
general and that's a shame because cars
3 wastes the potential of bringing army
hammer into the pixar world to voice
lightning mcqueen's latest rival jackson
storm utilizing the inherent bravado
that's so common in hammer's best work
only goes so far for a character whose
primary function is to just take the
slot of the film's big bad with not much
else to work off of
the best of the car's villains is chick
hicks lightning mcqueen's first rival
voiced by michael keaton as lightning
rests up and recovers in the small town
of radiator springs it's hicks jerkish
nature that gives mcqueen the constant
motivation to take him on in the film's
final race centerpiece and to give
keaton the credit he most definitely
deserves he certainly gives it his all
here as the arrogant race car whose only
glory can be found in a racing trophy
pixar's wally is a charming film about
two robots that doesn't necessarily need
a villain but it still positions otto
the starship axiom's autopilot software
as the antagonist whose programming
instructs it to stay the course and not
let anything get in its way not even the
chance to try and save earth otto is
certainly a fine means of creating
conflict in the final act of the film
but when it comes to ranking pixar
villains this machine is best seen as
more of a plot device than a fully
fleshed out character
the only character on this list voiced
by pixar's good luck charm john
ratzenberger the underminer provides the
perfect cap to the first incredibles
film teeing off another villain for the
super family to face off against
thankfully for all of us the underminer
digs right back into things in the
opening of incredibles 2. his clever
design kooky backstory an altogether
mischievous nature makes for a fun
villain that only needs a moment to
capture your attention
arriving over a decade after the
previous film in the series toy story 3
had a lot to live up to as the franchise
had already been deemed a cultural
classic and that same pressure was on
its villain lots of hug and bear or
lotso for sure fortunately just like the
film lotso exceeded expectations lotso
is positioned as the kindly caretaker of
the sunnyside daycare collection of toys
only to be revealed as a cruel and
dictatorial ruler making his fellow toys
suffer so that he can remain in power
even if his routine is something of a
new spin on the familiar arc of toy
story 2's previous villain stinky pete
lotsa huggin bear is still a wonderfully
designed instantly memorable character
that brings an air of cuddly menace to
the toy story universe
incredibles 2 delivered another
memorable villain with the devious and
overlooked evel endeavor voiced by
catherine keener dever is one of the two
heads of the dev tech telecommunications
company with her brother winston taking
on the face and branding of the company
leaving evelyn to deal with the actual
technology at play but evelyn still
burying a grudge against supers for the
death of her father uses her technology
to take down the superheroes and turn
society against them through an act of
violent hatred even if its messaging
gets a tad muddled near the end of the
film and her true villainy isn't as much
of a shock as the film wants it to be
evelyn is still a worthy foe for the
parr family to face in this most
wonderful super sequel
in the highly competitive world of
monsters inc where monsters face off
against each other to see who can get
the most screams from unsuspecting
children the heroes need an even scarier
villain and we get that and then some
with the film's scariest creature of all
randall boggs the terrifyingly slimy
scaly monster is designed to terrify
adults and children alike with his
chameleonic abilities providing him the
means to both sneak and scare to his
delight while we learn later in the film
how he's not the only villain to be
found in the hallways of monsters
incorporated randall is most certainly
the most memorable of the bunch when it
comes down to it and his competitive
nature and general creepiness are both
huge parts of that
with all our eyes focused on the menace
of randall boggs you would suspect the
ceo of monsters incorporated henry j
waternoose was the true mastermind
behind the devious plans at the center
of monsters inc water noose and fear of
the scare shortage plaguing monstropolis
turns to nefarious means of trying to
potentially kill children in order to
provide enough screams to fix their
energy crisis with enough paternal
energy to convince you of his
saintliness with a creepy bug-like
design that only becomes more menacing
as the film progresses waternews is a
classic example of a villain who thinks
he's doing what's right with seoul
focusing more on existential peril than
traditional movie threats the film is
forced to create some sort of
antagonistic force for our central
characters to bump up against so enter
terry the otherworldly being voiced by
rachel house who seems to be the only
one in the great before who makes us
feel a sense of dread or anxiety terry
is the accounting obsessed entity who's
on a mission to find out why the count
is off in the afterlife while filling a
gap that maybe wasn't necessary for this
kind of spiritual storytelling terry's
humor aesthetic and all-around
adventurous aura makes her a more than
memorable component of this soulful
piece of entertainment
another visit to the world of toys was
inevitable and toy story 4 was able to
rise to the occasion with a memorable
new villain we're talking about gabby
gabby who turned out to be a complex and
terrifying character an old-fashioned
doll with a broken voice box gabby just
wants to be played with and she knows
that woody's voice box is the only thing
that stands in her way of finally being
picked off the shelf at the antique
store it's this ultimate desire for
affection that puts her so high on this
list perhaps that's a surprise to many
but it's just as surprising that the
fourth entry in this long-running saga
could still ring tears out of our eyes
adventure is certainly out there in one
of pixar's most memorable films up when
carl frederickson comes face to face
with his childhood hero turned arch
nemesis the missing explorer charles
muns at first months is a welcoming
heroic presence until he discovers that
carl and his young friend russell have
befriended the elusive bird creature
he's been hunting
then muntz's kindness turns to menace
and carl's greatest inspiration quickly
turns into his greatest threat muntz's
dark and twisted obsession leads him
down a dangerous path with a legion of
talking dogs and it's also what
ultimately leads to his downfall a
classic villain in a classic performance
months is the perfect villainous foil
for this daring and emotional adventure
toy story pixar's feature-length debut
wants you to believe that sid an
extremely creative child who expresses
himself through highly imaginative
frankenstein-esque toy operations is
some kind of terrible evil person he
wears shirts with skulls on them and
rides a skateboard so clearly sid is a
monstrous young adult who's not to be
trusted
[Music]
let's go home and play
[Music]
sid has no idea the impact he's having
on these objects until they rise from
the ground to traumatize him he just
sees them as blueprints for his own
array of experimentation and even though
sid is positioned as woody and buzz's
worst nightmare there's still something
charming about his own unique version of
playtime
in ratatouille chef skinner is the
snobbish commercial head chef currently
running the lake cousteaus restaurant
and he stands as the only person in the
way of linguini taking over as the
rightful blood heir of gusto's legacy
with skinner's sights set on using the
gusto name to brand a collection of
frozen meals his love of food has turned
to well absolute trash and no long-lost
relative of gusto is going to get in the
way of that luckily for us a certain rat
chef is just a tad too cunning for
skinner to carry out his nefarious
anti-culinary schemes though skinner
still provides enough memorable menace
and conflict to leave a mark in this
stunning picture
in pixar's a bug's life a colony of ants
must face off against the oppressive
grasshoppers who've been abusing them
for years and no grasshopper is held in
more fearful esteem than the leader of
the pests himself hopper the demonic
insect with a huge distaste for ants and
a hunger for whatever food he can get
his hands on in the storybook world of a
bug's life hopper is the perfect
villainous foil needed to inspire the
ants to face him in the film's climactic
showstopper of a performance where our
heroes take hopper's only true weakness
his fear of birds and use it against him
even a few decades on this early creepy
crawly villain is still an absolute
standout
the best trick a pixar film can play is
hiding the villain in plain sight and
the captivating coco plays this trick
beautifully with the film's leading
musical talent ernesto de la cruz
brought to life by benjamin bratt de la
cruz is a musician who captures the
hearts and minds of both the living and
the dead and he's the primary
inspiration behind miguel's guitar
playing ambitions but it's only when our
protagonist unexpectedly journeys to the
land of the dead that he finds that de
la cruz's whole act has been built on a
web of lies in which ernesto killed his
songwriting partner and took credit for
his work miguel's hero turns right into
miguel's villain and de la cruz rises to
become one of pixar's best villains
anton ego begins ratatouille as the
skeletal food critic positioned as the
one to bring ultimate doom to chef
cousteau and his restaurant ego sends
fear and menace through the likes of
everyone who crosses his path including
chef gusto himself who dies in the wake
of one of his negative reviews but when
ego tastes the food cooked by the film's
rodent protagonist remy his attitude
changes leading to a glowing review for
gusto's restaurant and one of the most
elegant and beautiful odes to the art of
criticism ever seen in cinema history i
will be returning to gusto soon
hungry
for more
anyone can cook and as anton ego shows
anyone can turn their villainy into pure
heroism by a story's end
a nefarious early pixar villain stinky
pete pulls the brilliant trick of hiding
his true intentions from you until the
last possible moment then pulling the
rug out from under you in the most
chilling ingenious way possible in the
central conflict of toy story 2 stinky
pete represents the opposite of woody's
playful past he's a toy who's never been
played with and he'd rather keep it that
way after all he's been constantly
rejected by society so if he can't be
played with well no one can a complex
character plagued by his own
insecurities this prospector is easily
one of pixar's most memorable evil doers
perhaps it's fitting that for us the
best pixar villain is the one who turns
the act of villainy right on its head in
the incredibles syndrome was just a
mild-mannered superhero obsessive
rejected by his all-time idol mr
incredible that rejection hit him right
in his core leading him down a tech
obsessed path towards outright maniacal
villainy and turning him into the
red-headed hyper-villainous
super-killing syndrome that commands
both the incredibles and this very list
yeah i saved the best inventions for
myself
a perfect villain is usually the one who
thinks they're the real hero of the
story and that can certainly be said for
syndrome as classic a villain as they
come in the pixar universe or any other
cinematic universe for that matter
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite pixar movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]